hi my name is marina and i'm eight years
old today two chefs are gonna compete to
make my dream dish
hello marina hi
i'm riya i'm katie so what do you think
a witch would eat i would think they
would eat frogs
marina saying she wants a frog that's a
very specific amphibian wanna draw it
for us this is a plate
all right that's a frog that the good
witch would eat you know frog is edible
so maybe i buy a frog and cook it and i
would like drink broccoli oh pink
broccoli
yeah i love broccoli marina likes
broccoli
i'm just impressed with the children
that like vegetables i'm an adult and i
don't eat vegetables which is not the
message i want to send eat your broccoli
kids do you like cauliflower
not really okay pink broccoli i thought
aha
dye cauliflower into pink and then she
said she doesn't like cauliflower so
what are we what are we doing now
hair
oh
it's like spaghetti but it's hair it's
hair okay yeah usually if you find hair
on your dish you will send it back but
this time she asked for it because most
switches are ugly so they need good hair
yeah so this is like how she if she eats
this she's just gonna like get some
luscious locks going on is she taking
this hair from other people
yeah she's ripping hairs out okay okay
what's that it's a fly
oh
okay
flies
i'm kind of excited about the flies
not sure why so marina what kind of
fruit do you like
i love the chocolate
chocolate okay
is there any fruit you like i love
grapes
strawberries there's a lot going on on
this plate but i am pretty confident
that i can wow marina
and i'm just gonna sit back and work my
magic
like a wedge okay i think we have
everything we need this is great
away we go
so here's my plan for frog i'm going to
carve cantaloupe look like frog and use
grapes for eyes and put blueberry for
the flights i'm going to make chocolate
dipped strawberries with white chocolate
wings on it for broccoli i'm going to
make pink mashed potato and blanched
broccoli on top for the hair i'm going
to make threads made out of melted sugar
i'm going to make a giant oreo cookie
sandwich with a strawberry cream filling
i'm going to cover that in green candy
melts make marshmallow eyes make some
candy melt feet and legs and that's
gonna be my frog
then i'm gonna make flies out of
chocolate covered pretzels and some
raisinets
then i'm gonna make some broccoli out of
sugar cookies and a strawberry frosting
with some freezer dried strawberries on
the tops and finally i'm gonna make some
hair out of cookie dough and put a
little chocolate base on the bottom of
that
i'm gonna do mashed potato first
because it's gonna take a while
i hope it's gonna turn pink how are you
gonna turn it pink are you using like a
dye or i'm gonna start with
baits
and if it doesn't have pink i'm i have a
food coloring but i don't want to use it
if i don't need to uh i'm going to make
my oreo cookie dough right now i'm going
to cream my butter with my sugar
i just added egg and i added some
vanilla extract
i just put some flour cocoa powder some
baking soda in here i am not going to
immediately do this i used a spatula to
incorporate the sifted dry ingredients
just so that it didn't get all over the
place you're welcome oh thank you and
then i use the beaters to incorporate it
a little bit more and now i'm using my
hand to really like get it all together
and then after i'm finished with this
i'm going to wrap it up in some some
plastic wrap and i'll chill it for a
little bit i'm gonna go with this chill
so now i'm going to make chocolate gift
strawberry
now i'm gonna make my sugar cookie dough
i'm first gonna mix flour baking powder
we've got salt
and
oh
oh just put my sugar in that
what just put my sugar in my dry
ingredients sugar is a wet ingredient um
[Music]
is fine really has more cooking i don't
know
so it seems like katie is very nervous
she's messing up the process of making
cookie
but we are friends i want to support her
no matter what even though we are
competitors okay well no sugar with the
the butter so that's okay
we're okay
so water is boiling i'm going to add
potatoes
i'm making white chocolate wings wink
cool um okay
you're doing great thank you your little
wings look really real thank you my oreo
cookie dough has chilled and i'm gonna
do two things for it so this is gonna
make like the body of the frog
i'm gonna roll this out and cut it into
two big circles and then i'm gonna try
to make some like
cookie spaghetti for the experiment of a
lifetime so what it's your idea
i'm taking this slime juicer
and i'm gonna squeeze dough through it
she showed me the lemon squeezer to make
cookie hair
and i'm not sure how it's gonna come out
okay ready oh god please work oh oh oh
oh god you did it cookie hair oh that's
crazy it's a weird thing to say
the cookie spaghetti works this is a
thing
we are making this a thing okay so i'm
gonna heat up
cream
now my potatoes are done i'm going to
put them in a ricer with beets
oh my goodness
oh the beads coming out
are scary
secret to good mashed potato is don't
use food processor because it makes it
gummy
so i used potato razor
and i'm putting a lot of butter that
makes food delicious
and also i
learned from this show
that kids love cheese
so my dough has been chilling i'm now
rolling it out and these are going to be
my pink broccoli cookies
very rough cookies
now i'm blanching broccoli nice you have
to
get salt yeah salty like seawater
right now i'm making the filling for the
frog cookie and the frosting for the
broccolis
so first i'm going to do some cream
cheese
and a little butter
i like to do the cream cheese it'll cut
the sweetness down a bit
why can't i handle that okay now i'm
going to add some strawberry preserves
we can always add you can't take away
wow this look like a fly that's not cute
difficult to fridge
right now i'm gonna carve
this
counter off this is exciting i'm cutting
it's open mouth and i'm gonna stuff with
grapes ooh
is that his feet yeah oh my god
that's so cute
i'm gonna crush some dehydrated
strawberries at the very top of these
guys so that they have the broccoli tops
so this seed's gonna be eyeball
look
oh my gosh does it look like a frog
though yeah i wanna be his friend
i'm so proud of myself right now so i'm
gonna just put in a
nice little stun did you say you're so
proud of yourself
look my frog
are you are you just plain yeah oh my
god
again a new side of you right now right
now i'm whipping up some whipped cream
and i'm gonna fold the frosting in just
so that it's a lighter filling for the
cookie
okay great cookie
done i'm gonna go put that in the fridge
while i melt my candy melts
i'm melting sugar and it's gonna be look
like a caramel and i just melted some
chocolate and i'm gonna be making my
flies right now using chocolate covered
raisins and some flips
so do you just eyeball when it's ready
like you don't use a thermometer i was
gonna use thermometer but i've done that
before because i feel like i no oba
estimated myself oh no
yeah i think it's too dark now sorry
gotta go
for the sugar hair i've made it before
i'm pretty confident so i didn't look
recipe
but it's not working we do redo take two
take two so thread stage thread stage
okay the thread stage it's 2 15. okay
this time i'm gonna
oh so i think that's under a boil
softball i think i was a little bit too
relaxed today
i didn't even
measure how much sugar i added what if i
have to do it start a time you know
third time is the charm
number so
i'm gonna put this cookie in this okay
pour it over it what would you do i
would have pour over okay whatever a
says
i'm gonna do it yeah okay pouring over
here goes nothing
i'm gonna go put this in the fridge
right now okay okay if i fail this time
i'm gonna follow the recipe
katie
i think i have to do it again okay
third time's the challenge time to
challenge three's the magic number this
is our motto riya is starting over and
i'm alarmed i've never seen this before
she's human she's maybe beatable okay so
i'm using the rest of my candy melts i
put it in a bag i'm going to try to pipe
out some legs and some feet for my frog
i failed a second time so i'm
looking a recipe half cup of sugar
in half cup of corn syrup
okay it looks better than before i'm
gonna make a weird
lily pad for plating out of purple
because she drew a purple plate yeah i
kind of look like witch it's like
bubbling i'm gonna put on the eyeballs
now it's crazy
i love it hello
i'm a frog
this is his voice oh yeah it's happening
it's cracking
oh no
everything's coming together but my my
frog is starting to crack
i really gotta just get this guy
together okay it's okay
he's good enough
no one needs to see that some of his
cookie
fell away
oh hey you're making it it's finally
working i follow the recipe
sorry at a time it's a charm i think
she's gonna like it look like a
spiderweb it looks cool
it looks like you're a witch right now
you're like yeah
i'm having fun katie me too
i'm putting his feet oh
his feet are funny
ah
look at that
all right i'm gonna play
[Music]
his like one leg is so much bigger than
the other leg
[Music]
i think that ries frog is is really fun
and mine is like kind of creepy but i
like him he has personality i named him
jerry we did it why am i hungry
[Laughter]
my cantaloupe frog doesn't look like
pinterest fail my flights look delicious
my broccoli pans are super pretty i gave
everything marina wanted and i'm pretty
confident i'm really happy with how my
dish turned out the frog is so cute and
fun my broccoli turned out to look like
pink broccoli and if marina likes sweets
she's gonna like this
bring on my witch's feast
wow
i think it looks amazing
i love i love the frog it's really cool
i love that there's grapes inside of it
i'll try the hair first
[Music]
wow the hair is really good
wow it tastes like the broccoli that my
mom makes it tastes exactly how i wanted
it to taste mom's cooking the best my
confidence will stop
wow it's really soft
i really like it
i'm gonna try the pink
i don't really know what it tastes like
oh starting to taste not that good
tastes like mashed potatoes
i don't really like mashed potatoes who
doesn't like mashed potato i also put
cheese in there and she hates it i don't
really like regular mashed potatoes
so
i just think i don't like pink ones
either the pink mashed potato might have
cost me for the competition
wow
that looks amazing i like how it the
frog
looks like that i really like the bugs
it looks really artistic
that's really good
i'll try the broccoli next
wow
tastes like strawberries
[Music]
wow this tastes really good this is like
chocolate covered raisins
what i made bugs taste good
the hair
[Music]
wow
and the hair is really good
she's like brownie
i think the letter pad is
white chocolate but
it doesn't taste that good ah she
doesn't like the lily pad that was a
last-minute decision i shouldn't have
done it but it's the only thing she
doesn't like so i think i'm still in the
game
hello
hi
so which one did you like better the
melon frog or the cake frog
it's really hard to choose but i like
the
melon
ray because you want you got my drawing
thank you so much this is so cool i'm so
sad
we not win a witch dinner
thank you for telling us which one you
liked better
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you